Jean-Michel Leprince.
- Contrairement à toute attente,
l'iaiation ukrainienne vole
encore et inflige des pertes
à l'envahisseur russe,
mais elle réclame de l'aide.
C'est pourquoi le président
Volodymyr Zelensky réclame
sans répit, à défaut
d'une zone d'exclusion
aérienne, des avions.
Des avions, des tanks
et des armes antimissiles.
Malgré cette infériorité,
cet ancien aviateur militaire
français prédit ceci :
XAVIER TYTELMAN, consultant
en aéronautique, Air & Cosmos
- Il y a une certitude qui
s'est installée : les Russes ne
peuvent plus gagner la guerre.
- Pourquoi? Parce que
d'abord, les Russes, de façon
surprenante, n'ont toujours pas
la maîtrise deiririr puisque
les Sukhoi volent encore.
- Évidemment, il y a
cette capacité de l'aviation
à continuer àererer, mais
il y a également une défense
aérienne qui était très bien
fournie avant la guerre.
Ils avaient certainement entre
150 et 200 systèmes de haute
altitude, des systèmes Bouk,
des systèmes S-300. Ceux-là,
il y a une grande partie qui
est encore opérationnelle,
et c'est pour ça qu'on voit
encore aujourd'hui, par exemple,
un Sukhoi 30 russe
qui a été abattu.
(détonations)
-  o o o où les Occidentaux
ne lésinent pas, ce sont
sur les lance-missiles,
comme le Javelin américain.
Il coûte moins de 100 000 $
e e e envoie des missiles par
guidage thermique capable de
percer n'importe quel blindage.
Les Américains en ont envoyé
plus de 4000.
- Ça s'accroche à
l'infrarouge, par exemple,
sur les hélicoptères, et
c'est pour ça que la Russie
a perdu plusieurs dizaines
d'hélicoptères, certainement
plus de 40, parce que
ces systèmes sont faciles
à utiliser et qu'on les a
fournis en très grande quantité.
Et l'autre avantage également,
c'est que les Russes, manquant
de munitions de précision,
ils sont obligés de fa
voler leurs avions en très
basse altitude et, justement,
ils descendent à une altitude
à laquelle ils sont à portée
de ses missiles
depuis les pôles qui
sont très, très simples.
- Pour les convois
et les blindés, la grande
suststststst l'efficacité
d'un drone turque déjà
bien connu et qui n'est pas
très cher : le Bayraktar TB2.
- Et la majorité des choses
qui volent sont des drones,
notamment les drones...
ce qu'on appelle les TB2,
les Bayraktar d'origine turque
a a a a a priori, ont une très
grande efficacité et que
les Russes n'arrivent pas
toujours à identifier
et donc à détruire.
(détonation)
- Les Ukrainiens
ne tarissent pas d'éloges
pour le drone turque.
(détonations)
Tout comme pour le missile
antichar suédois fourni
par les Britanniques, le NLAW.
(explosion)
- Ce sont des missiles qui sont
tirés depuis les pôles, et ça,
contre lesèèèèèères russes,
contre les avions de chasse
quand ils sont obligés de
voler en basse attitude,
ça, évidemment, ça fait
m m m m m mal.
- Les Américains ont promis
une centaine de missiles
Switchblade. Petit, léger,
mo i i i i i i il s'ouvre
en vol comme un canif,
d'où le nom, et il est
extrêmement prometteur.
- Parce que ces petits drones
Switchblade, on ne peut pas
les intercepter ni au radar,
ni en infrarouge, donc
les Russes vont être
totalement vulnérables face
à ces systèmes qui vont être
livrés dans les prochains jours.
Sur le terrain, réellement,
l'arrivée des Switchblade,
ça peut transformer
la capacité offensive
de l'armée ukrainienne.
- C'est une sorte de drone-ssss,
car il se détruit sur sa cible.
Il est tenu encore assez secret.
Ces armes, qui sont en train
de changer l'art de la guerre,
ont des effets dévastateurs
pour les Russes.
- Si on ususususususususses ont
perdu quasiment 2000 blindés,
on peut se dire qu'il y a
au moins 8000 à 10 000 morts
du côté russe.
Et ensuite, on a toujours
deux à trois fois plus de
blessés que ce qu'on a de morts,
et c'est donc certainement
30 000 à 40 000 personnes qui
sont incapables de combattre
aujourd'hui, sans compter
ceux qui sont aujourd'hui
enfermés dans certaines poches.
Vous savez, par exemple...
(inaudible)
... il y a eu une contre-
offensive ukrainienne
qui a certainement bloqué
des milliers de Russes quisont t
encerclés. Donc au total,
on estime qu'il y a au moins
un quart de l'armée russe
qui est prise, morte
ou inapte au combat.
- Malgré ces pertes,
mais à cause de la puissance
de son armée, la Russie pourrait
encore gagner la guerre,
mais pas la guerre
qu'elle avait prévue.
Ici Jean-Michel Leprince,